stéfane marion et économiste en chef et
stratège en chef de la banque nationale
bonsoir et puis vincent delisle et co
chef des placements chez hexavest
bonsoir monsieur soir merci d'être avec
nous ce soir monsieur mario d'abord un
mot sur l' annonce d'eric girard
aujourd'hui c'est important ce type
d'intervention du gouvernement
je pense que c'est crucial on doit
soutenir le revenu disponible aux
ménages surtout ceux qui n'ont pas accès
au filet subjectif social dans toute son
étendue
donc je pense que c'est une mesure qui
est bienvenu et il y en aura donc au
cours des prochaines semaines comme quoi
à quoi faut-il s'attendre dans les
prochains jours moi je pense qu'au
niveau du fédéral on doit abandonner
toutes les cibles budgétaires co s'était
fixé même chose pour les provinces
moi je pense que le déficit fédéral doit
passer d'un ordre de grandeur du autour
de 20 milliards de dollars à peut-être
100 milliards de dollars ce qu'il
réussit en pourcentage d'économie cat et
demi pour cent à peu près je pense que
c'est raisonnable pour composer avec
l'effet sur l'économie tant au niveau
des ménages qu'au niveau des entreprises
on doit soutenir les 200 milliards pour
le budget de 2020 21
je pense que c'est le type de mesure
c'est le type d'ordre de grandeur auquel
on doit s'attendre du fédéral au cours
des prochaines semaines et donc un plan
de stimulation économique majeur soutien
aux ménages soutien aux entreprises faut
comprendre monsieur fillion que les
entreprises qui sont touchés par les
fermetures de glandes grandes
agglomérations urbaines sont deux fois
plus intensive en main d'oeuvre quand
pib dont 14% du pib mais 28% des emplois
donc c'est important de protéger
l'entreprise parcs sont des générateurs
d'emplois les petites tasses entreprises
et aussi aider les ménages à subvenir à
leurs besoins essentiels au cours des
prochaines semaines
vincent delisle quand j'entends cela
forte intervention des gouvernements
forte interventions des banques
centrales qui ont relevé entre nous deux
l'évolution du s p 500 depuis le début
de l'année la chute s'amplifie toujours
pourquoi pourquoi les investisseurs
réagissent de cette façon c'est une
crise sans précédent de par sa nature
lors les récession historique carrie par
des chocs économiques l'eau
virus qui est pris tout le monde par
surprise la rapidité également leur on
le voit sur le graphique à l'écran on
parle de baisse de 30% du s&p 500 depuis
moins d'un mois c'est la cgem est arrivé
ça alors on est tombés en marché
baissier en bear market le plus
rapidement de l'histoire
au début je rappeler qu'en 2009 de 2007
à 2009 on avait eu une chute de 57%
celui là et là on à 30% en trois quatre
semaines en trois quatre semaines alors
2008 c'est la crise financière dont tout
le monde se rappelle c'est le dernier
épisode qui nous a tous marqués mais ça
avait commencé au milieu 2007 de
l'économie américaine avait trop bas
natation il ya eu la faillite de lehman
brothers dont un choc
le livre eu un choc double dans le
dernier mois un choc en asie avec le
chrono virus la production s'est arrêtée
en chine sa traversée en europe s'est
rendu en amérique du nord il ya un choc
de demande alors les deux gros acteurs
économiques de la planète sont en
hibernation de la vie bien mentionné
c'est arrivé en accéléré les banques
centrales ressortent leur arsenal qu'il
nous avait présenté pour pauvres pour
combattre la crise financière de 2008
ils ont appris il ya de nouveaux outils
dans leur coffre à outils mais ce qui
est très important et monsieur mario le
mentionner ce que le gouvernement
canadien est ce que le vent québécois
offert emerich et le support des
dépenses gouvernementales va être
impératif pour s'assurer que ramener la
confiance sur les marchés de s'assurer
que cette récession là ne soit pas trop
longue et pas trop douloureuse
alors aujourd'hui on évoqué la
possibilité d'un soutien de 800
milliards à l'économie aux états unis un
plan de stimulation économique donc on
revisite les chiffres qu'on avait connue
en 2008 2009 se dit cet événement les
différents la crise financière on parle
pas d'un problème de liquidités au
niveau des banques on parle d'un choc
d'offre qui combiné avec la fermeture
des vielles peut amener un choc de
demande donc choc de demande ce qui veut
dire des effets sur marché du travail à
moyen terme
les gens font beaucoup de parallèles
avec la pandémie du début du siècle
dernier mais je vais faire c'est
important de mentionner qu à l'époque le
taux d'urbanisation qui se mentent 40%
l'on pense qu'on presse après être comme
10000 me 118 1919 moi j'ai donc cela est
différent parce que
les pib les gens sont en zone urbaine
donc d'un côté c'est plus facile à
contrôler ça fait plus mal au pib à
court terme
mais mon dieu qu'on peut écraser la
courbe d'épidémie beaucoup plus
rapidement et ce qui me réconforte
présentement que de certains pays où on
le fait de gens la corée du sud
on voit depuis quelques jours une baisse
considérable des nouveaux camps à une
remontée spectaculaire des gens qui sont
en guérison
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à une
nouvelle baisse de la banque du canada
moi je pense qu'on a atteint 1 écoutez
on peut pas l'exclure les etats-unis
sont un peu plus haut que nous nous
sommes par contre nous avons la capacité
de déployer plus rapidement le stimuli
budgétaires au canada qu'aux états unis
et dans ce contexte là je pense que
peut-être les taux canadiens pourraient
baisser légèrement
est-ce qu'on va aller aussi bas que les
états unis au vert on est à 50 points de
base seulement mais je pense que c'est
le maintenant partir de maintenant c'est
vraiment le stimuli budgétaires qui
compte
vincent delisle pourquoi tout chute le
prix de l'or valeur refuge historique
chute aussi pourquoi la semaine dernière
est une semaine assez atypique donc
correction sévère sur les marchés
boursiers mais actifs refuges
obligations du trésor américain le prix
de l'or a mentionné même le yen japonais
ont tous eu une semaine difficile parce
qu'il faut y voir et si c'est que les
sorties de fonds les liquidations de
grands fonds de couverture les fans la
panique généralisée des investisseurs
les grands et petits alors quand on vend
on se soucie peu de quoi on va on veut
amener des liquidités alors tout tout y
est passé
je vous dirais la semaine dernière donc
il ya eu d'énormes différenciation ça a
été une sortie et tout le monde
cherchait la sortie d aucune protection
il n'y a pas eu de protection la semaine
dernière ses revenus un petit peu
aujourd'hui normalement ce à quoi on
devrait assister ces les actifs plus
défensifs moins sensibles 7 à ce fort
ralentissement économique lorsqu on
pourrait fermer la bourse
certaines beaucoup de jeunes hommes en
soit on peut on pourrait essayer de
fermer après les les
les accidents tragiques du 11 septembre
il y avait eu une pause à la bourse
le message qui serait lancée pour être
prêt d'être prêté de plusieurs façons je
pense pas que c'est une nécessité
les 6 marion mentionner les mesures
d'amélioration les chiffres qui
s'améliorait en asie notamment en corée
lorsqu'on va voir la progression de
cette pandémie la s'atténuer en europe
et éventuellement avoir des taux succès
en amérique du nord peut-être dans deux
semaines peut-être dans quatre semaines
sa voix je pense que ça va réduire un
peu la tension sur le marché mais ce qui
va être prioritaire on parle beaucoup de
ce que le canada peut faire ce que les
états unis vont faire l'europe l'europe
tarder à arriver avec des solutions au
niveau budgétaire c'est toujours plus
difficile c'est plus difficile
politiquement mais au fait valoir que
les unit les ministres du g7 que ce soit
une offre concerne créer une approche
concertée et qui viennent des dépenses
gouvernementales je voyais aujourd'hui
que 95% des grandes entreprises à
l'extérieur de l'épicentre en chine la
province de hubei ont relancé leurs
activités donc vraiment on est en train
de repartir dernière question pour vous
est-ce que l'action de la fed de la
réserve fédérale américaine ajoute à
l'anxiété en ce moment où si le remède
c'est comme ça qu'il faut que ça se
passe je crois pas ça qui est optimale
au niveau de la communication de la
réserve fédérale en y allant du coup sur
coup avec des mesures sans précédent
surtout dans le créneau horaire dont on
parle en investissement c'est ça un peu
spécial d'autant plus que la réunion
était cette semaine
moi je pense que bon on craignait une
crise de liquidité on voulait s'assurer
de rassurer les marchés mais encore une
fois - je répète qu'à partir de
maintenant c'est le rôle des
gouvernements on doit mettre des mesures
en place pour passer à travers les huit
prochaines semaines deux mois voilà
stéfane marion vincent de l'est merci
beaucoup